damn you and Twitter why do you stay on
Twitter
I like why the people up yeah that one
you really do don't know without that's
what it's about you know I mean it's
like everyone's a bit square up and all
are not really that one's just a bit
serious and miserable you know I mean I
do like minded people you know I mean I
do like the Mindil back you know I mean
but yeah there's a bit a lot of these
rock and roll stars these days they're
coming and just getting the check out
and going on imagine Keith Moon John
these are softening going on you know a
few things are that Bob the tweet I mean
knows that you some have a bit a little
bit like out of order and I do apologize
she may not thought recently when you
were hacked for as a police
investigation but but previously you had
how real is that is that like a game and
then you like you slap each other on
Twitter and then you phone each other
apart and I love yeah oh god no that's
well for real man is it really
we don't like each other much a lot of
people think we're waiting around you
know I mean for like a few more knots on
the end for the thing but they've
already offered us like loads of money
like millions and millions but not about
the money is it you know what I mean
yeah me and Loomis squared away only for
10 minutes because he threw my hat
across the bar now you started you go
yeah in your happiness
let me feel he's a gave my hug you know
he got he didn't like that because he
loves his hair so by doing so we had a
little girl get now
great
[Music]